All right.
Foglight says,
I love this guy.
Well,
thank you.
Fog Light.
I would probably love you too if I knew
you.
Let's see.
Okay,
who's at Santa Christ says,
I'm a monster.
Roar.
Good.
Well,
that's a good start,
man.
That's a good start.
Practice that roar
and get good at it because there'll be
times when you need it.
So
Dj chronic says,
I let myself be that week monster for so
long.
Yeah,
well maybe you know what it's like,
man,
down in your basement fantasizing about
revenge.
That's no bloody fun.
But you know,
this is something now for an Adler new
too.
He's worth reading those fantasies of
revenge.
You know,
they have the seeds within them.
Young knew this as well.
The seeds within them of the new you.
You can let those fee.
You can let those fantasies.
What would you say?
Manifest themselves and see what seeds
of potential future development or
harbored within them.
That's also extremely useful.